this video is sponsored by Skillshare if
you want to learn how you can get a free
trial and learn the real-life connection
hidden in the nun then stick around to
the end of this video we don't have an
official trailer for the norm to follow
the teaser trailer that's been playing
in cinemas but we do have a lot of
content to analyze in the form of these
TV spots entitled Abbie coffin visions
discover reveal and investigate so on
that note let's investigate some these
commercials
[Music]
[Music]
to fire
[Music]
so it starts on this radio which that's
the soundtrack for this commercial it's
a cover of some enchanted evening from
the 1949 musical South Pacific in South
Pacific the song is sung by a French
plantation owner about a woman he's just
met but he instantly knows he will see
her again because it's love at first
sight
[Music]
aside from the you will see a stranger
line taking a creepier meaning in a
horror movie the broader themes of the
song within the context of the piece
also become more interesting the
character in South Pacific describes the
feeling of knowing that he'll see the
girl again whereas the characters in the
conjuring franchise Ed Warren Lorraine
Warren and this new character sister
Irene all have psychic premonitions
about the demon this crazy dream saw
this thing I had a vision in a medieval
I had a premonition of your death you've
seen it too the demon in your painting
is real when a psychic has a premonition
it's something that they'll know they'll
see again in the future just as a meal
from South Pacific knows that he'll see
his love again these characters know
they'll be seeing Valek again on some
enchanted evening this shot shows the
sisters sleeping next to this pool of
water but notice how she's vertical
compared to the horizontal body of water
so this is a composite shot I think the
director wanted us to see her dream and
her reaction at the same time and I
think her dream could be related to this
other shot we see in the commercial a
VALIC lurking in the water and I've said
it once and I'll say it again these
water scenes are getting really popular
lately obviously they're going to be a
lot of crosses since it's set in an
abbey but there seem to be a symbolic
struggle going on between the crosses a
sign of faith and religion and inverted
crosses a sign of demons and the occult
there are even a couple of instances of
crosses being rotated 180 degrees become
inverted crosses which could be a symbol
of someone being converted to Satanism
this might be a big part of the film
because even the title card for the nun
sneaks in a cross being turned upside
down you pause as the father is
researching about VALIC the text is too
blurry to make out but we do have a
couple of intriguing illustrations the
one on the left is a picture of Alec but
not in the nun for more used to seeing
the nun form is actually something that
was made up
for the conjuring too Valek was an
existing character from the 17th century
spell book known as the Lesser Key of
Solomon the purpose of the book was
supposedly to teach people about how to
conjure demons basically like a 17th
century equivalent of it Lance Stewart
and it's also the book that details King
Haemon from another recent horror movie
hereditary which I also have a things
you missed on but in the Lesser Key of
Solomon
Valek is described as a terrifying demon
child with wings riding on a two-headed
dragon it's possible that this drawing
of Alec is more of a reference to that
Alec's true form and that the nun is
just an alternate this other picture
appears to be a read ed from ocarina of
time with a giant serpent coming out of
his face so maybe that's like a third
form of Alec here's the next thing you
missed
[Music]
did you see it let me slow that down for
you look right here well that's just
terrifying so here's one of the inverted
crosses that I mentioned earlier the
fire seems to have been started from a
dropped lantern remember what happened
at the end of the teaser trailer my
guess is that these incidents are
related but it could also be from this
character the next spot is visions but I
didn't really find anything significant
in that so let's move on to discover in
1952 the Vatican investigated the events
at the abbey of Saint card this is what
they discovered okay so for this one I
want you to look at the backgrounds this
image shows a bunch of grave plots this
one is a chapel this one looks like one
of the characters is in a crucifix
position possibly tying into the cross
motif mentioned earlier and in this last
one we see more of the graves and we
discovered that they're out front of the
abbey the narration here almost implies
that the movie is based on a true story
like all the conjuring films but also
like all the conjuring films the story
is clearly fiction but there are some
true characters places and events in
this case the setting the abbey of Saint
Cara in Romania is a real place and some
tourism websites claim that it's haunted
the abbey was home to the order of the
Cistercians
a group of Roman Catholic monks and nuns
who became known as the white monks
because of the color of their garb they
all died in their mid-30s due to extreme
fasting practices and poor living
conditions and were buried inside the
abbey
priests and visitors have since claimed
that the abbey is haunted by the monks
who once lived there sighting moving
chairs and vibrating walls these graves
seen at the Abbey could be in reference
to the haunting of the white monks and
there may be other connections which
I'll get back to first let's watch the
next spot reveal role
so I'm guessing these are the spirits of
the white monks haunting the monastery
and VALIC has taken over one of them and
wouldn't you know it he's in a crucifix
position but if you look closely he
seems to be standing on a big pentagram
you can see it a little bit better in
the final shots moving on now to coffin
[Music]
so I wouldn't be surprised if this also
ties into the idea of the burial of the
white monks there's also a little string
he's pulling on when he's trapped inside
the coffin which I'm guessing is tied to
this Bell on the tombstone let it be
known that when I die I would like to
have this feature on my coffin in case I
come back as a zombie actually just
build a big fire on home plate at
Wrigley Field and toss my coffin in roll
the next thought here to investigate the
death of a nun September 7
witness the Turkish chapter the defiant
in the country universe
if you pause and look at these lighting
fixtures they appear to possibly be the
wing to child form of VALIC and if you
pause on the shot you'll see that this
is the door that I talked about when I
did the episode on the Nam teaser
trailer that says vineet Hickey daija or
God ends here it may lead to the
corridor first scene at the end of
Annabel creation one of the legends
about the white monks tell about a
tunnel that was dug from the Abbey to a
nearby river that could have been used
to escape in the event of an invasion
perhaps this corridor is supposed to be
that very tunnel I do get questions from
time to time asking about how I make
these videos and how to be a youtuber
and stuff so I've decided to partner
with Skillshare to hook you all up with
an amazing free offer Skillshare is an
online learning platform where you can
take classes directly from experts in
your field and it doesn't just have to
be technical skills you can learn fun
stuff that you'll use all the time like
how to build out your Instagram or how
to Photoshop yourself into a horror
movie image there's literally a class
for that this could be you and the great
thing about Skillshare is you actually
have people who know what they're doing
I think all of us have tried to look up
some tutorials before and ended up
getting something from some
eight-year-old kid from the UK you can't
understand what the heck he's saying
because he's recording in an actual tin
can well with Skillshare you'll be
treated to high-quality documentary
style lessons created by teachers with
credentials and another issue with
random online tutorials is that you
can't go at your own pace if I'm trying
to learn how to achieve a VHS look and
after effects I don't need you to teach
me how to download and open the program
first you eight-year-old kid from Wales
but with Skillshare lessons are broken
up into sections so you can quickly find
exactly what you want to learn and
become an expert for a limited time
Skillshare is hooking up viewers of C
Z's world with two free modes just click
the link in the description to get
started and even if you don't have
something you want to learn right now
I'd recommend taking that free trial
anyways and then as soon as you do need
to look something up you'll just be a
click away you're gonna be finding
tutorials for things you didn't even
know you wanted to learn so once again
just click the link in the description
right now to get two free months of this
premium service but that's gonna do it
for these commercials for the none and
for Skillshare if you're excited to see
this film leave me a like on this video
and if you love horror movies you have
come to the right place remember to
subscribe to see ZZZ world for new
Horrors every week ring that death bell
for notifications and I'll see you in
the next one
assuming we both survive